so I wanted to create a video to answer
the question that keeps coming up will
the bulletproof coffee prevent a toughie
G okay I've done videos on will it
prevent you know ketosis but now let's
talk about a top of G toffee G is an
amazing state when you go into fasting
mode your body starts repairing you
start recycling the damaged proteins and
the microbes in the body and the viruses
and the candida starts cleaning up all
this stuff the need for vitamins and
nutrients go way down because your body
is in recycled mode it gets very very
efficient our bodies were designed tens
of thousands of years ago to not eat
very frequently so we have this great
survival skill that helps us in many
different ways so it's like a
self-cleaning oven sort of speak in your
cells so what will stop a toughie G the
glucose is right at the top of the list
protein cortisol how do you get this
from stress okay stress will shut that
down like that not that you've ever
experienced dress but you probably know
people who have eating will will stop a
toughie G okay so we really want to do
fasting low stress and then not consume
these fat has the least effect on
insulin so that's exciting so let's say
for example you're doing bulletproof
coffee where you're adding some coconut
oil or MCT oil or even butter and you're
doing like a lot of it okay where
there's like three four hundred calories
yeah well that's gonna stop your etapa G
absolutely it's gonna block it but if
you're doing a small amount let's say
one tablespoon of butter or 1 tablespoon
of MCT oil it may inhibit etapa G for a
little bit but I don't think it's gonna
be that significant now if you do half
and half it does have one percent
carbohydrate and one in less than one
percent protein
so now we're getting the carbs but these
have no carbs okay so maybe you just do
a very very small amount of this and
that might be the ideal situation but to
get in the tofu G really depends on
several things the amount of calories
that you're consuming which we just
talked about the more the less etapa G
we have so it's a balance act also your
health state your age for 18 years old
and have an incredible metabolism you
can probably get into top of G way
faster than someone going through
menopause but let's say you have a
diabetic and you're a medication well
that's gonna inhibit your top of G too
so it really dependent to on your health
state the worst your health is the more
strict that you need to be with these
things the healthier you are the more
you can get away with this okay the
faster the metabolism the more you can
get away with this
okay let's say for example you exercise
well that will help you get into top the
G because that's one of the triggers so
it because you're actually creating this
stress on top you're not eating so
you're gonna create more ikata G as long
as you recover because we don't want to
increase too much cortisol from the
excessive stress that you just created
also there's another factor of how long
your fasting let's say for example
you're doing one meal a day well that's
great because you're gonna have a lot of
hours to do to get into a top of G right
I would imagine you get into a really
good etapa G right around 18 hours it
could be 16 hours it could be a little
bit later it really depends on they
don't really know exactly but I'm just
using that as a good ballpark number 18
hours of fasting okay so if you're let's
say you're getting exactly 18 hours or
17 hours and you're doing this well
you're probably not going to get the
benefits as compared to doing your
fasting let's say at 20 hours and with a
four-hour window of eating okay
so there's you can see that it's not a
simple answer you have to look at all
these factors and use
judgment on this but the longer the fast
the more you can get away with this okay
and also how much insulin you have in
your body because insulin or block or
topic g2 so you say well I don't have
any more carbohydrates well you may have
insulin resistance and insulin
resistance causes your own body to make
it more insulin like five to seven times
more that extra insulin can keep you
from experiencing the benefits of etapa
G and this is why the etapa G benefits
even living longer and better skin and
into aging occur more over time of doing
a healthy Kido and in a min fasting plan
because you're you're building on this
your body's becoming more efficient your
insulin is coming way way down okay so
it's really a balance of a balancing act
there's a certain hormone factor called
GIP it's located in your small
intestines and this is triggered when
you eat so it amplifies the effects of
insulin so it's not just a matter of
avoiding carbs it's a matter of also
keeping your calories really low okay
but I would imagine if you're in pretty
good shape and you just do a small
amount of one of these in your coffee I
don't think it's going to be a big
problem okay but you have to test it out
and see see if you're getting the
benefits that your better skin feeling
younger the cognitive improvements and
by the way as a side note I'm gonna do a
separate video on this vitamin D is will
help you get into top of G more so Sun
is really good too so if we combine Sun
with exercise with fasting it'll improve
your potential for etapa G benefits
alright so I think I covered all the
points and I will see you in the next
video
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it